Hi everyone, we're about to start the
next session. Thank you guys so much for
coming out today. Um, this is going to
be a build your own sales agent
workshop. So, we're going to be walking
through everything you need to know to
build your own voice agent. My name is
Sarah Chang from Cerebras and I am
excited to be joined by Genway. Um, and
we are both part of the DevX team at
Cerebras.
>> Yeah, thanks Sarah. Um, so today we're
going to walk through how to build a
voice sales agent that can actually have
a natural conversations with customers
and our sales agents will pull product
contacts from an external source to
respond in real time. So, we're going to
be building an AI agent that can speak,
listen, and respond intelligently
um to your company's sales materials.
And we have the full code for you to
follow along with. We have a notebook
that you can scan later um to step ghost
and we'll walk you through it step by
step in just a moment.
So, before we get started, let's go
through what you will get out of this
workshop. So you will get free API
credits for Cerebrris livekit cartisia.
You will have the quick start. We'll
have again have a full code notebook for
you to follow along with and at the end
you will have your very own sales agent
that you can hook up to your company's
materials so that you can you know
implement this in production.
So here's the starter code that I would
recommend scanning just so you can
follow along. Um, again, this is what
we'll be walking through step by step
today. And there will be individual
modules that you'll be able to just run
and see some good outfits.
So, I'll give you a few seconds for
that.
We'll have the QR code later as well, so
not to worry. So, before we get started,
I wanted to talk a little bit about
Cerebrus and, you know, Cerebrus
inferences secret sauce. So, for those
of you who are unfamiliar, we are a
hardware company. We are building an AI
processor that is much larger and much
faster than what you are probably
familiar with with Nvidia GPUs. So out
of curiosity, I'm wondering how many
people here have heard about Cerebras
hardware. Not bad. Okay. Higher than
last year. Okay. Okay. So before we do
go, I want to share um I want to show
everyone the speed of what we're talking
about here. So So
this is just a chat. It's running on
Cerebras. You can choose any. So, we can
host any different model on our
hardware. So, I'm going to choose an
example model like a llama model. And
I'm going to give it a prompt. So, I'm
going to give it a prompt that it's
intentionally asking it to respond
something a little longer. This go
funny dad jokes, but make each joke a
couple sentences.
Sentences.
And that's how fast it generates. Does
anyone else have a prompt you want to
try? A longer prompt.
>> Amazing. There you go.
So, really quickly before we get
started, I know we have a lot of
software geeks here, but I do want to
for a second talk about hardware. And I
want to talk a little bit about what
hardware innovations
um make such fast inference possible
especially as we build a new generation
of AI products.
And so we're going to a little bit of a
hardware segment, but one of the main
secret sauces for Cerebras is that
Cerebras chips do not have memory
bandwidth issues. And I don't know how
familiar you guys are with, you know,
GPU architecture, but we're actually
gonna de deep dive really quickly into
how GPU architecture works and how it
compares to what people are doing today.
And so for context, this is the hardware
that, you know, all of our inference
runs on. It's the wafer scale engine 3.
It is quite literally the size of a
dinner plate. And this has 4 trillion
transistors, 900,000 cores, and very
significant amounts of onchip memory.
And so this is the comparison of what
our hardware looks like next to the
NVIDIA GPU. So you can see some of those
metrics line up. So significantly more
transistors.
But to actually understand what Cerebras
did with their hardware that is makes it
able to achieve 20x 30x f 70x faster
speeds than in inference on Nvidia GPUs.
We're going to actually start by taking
a look at the Nvidia GPU. So this is a
diagram of an H100.
And if you look at the red rectangle,
that is a core. And so on the H100
there's about 17,000 cores and each of
these cores is the is what is actually
doing all of the mathematical
computations needed in training or
inference or whatever computation you
need to do. So every core has a subset
of the computations um that is assigned.
So when you run inference what are some
of the types of things that a core will
need access to to do its computation? it
needs its weight, activations, KV cache,
etc. On the H100, all of these values
are stored offchip. So, they're stored
in an offchip memory. And so, as you can
imagine, during inference, each of these
cores, there's thousands of computations
happening constantly. And each core is
needing to constantly load and offload
the KV cache, activation, weights, etc.
from an off-memory location. And as you
can imagine this creates a very
significant memory channel um memory
bandwidth bottleneck.
What Cerebrris has done instead is that
instead of storing all these values off
chip every single core on the Cerebrus
hardware the WSC3 there's 900,000 cores
which in comparison to 17,000 is already
a lot larger. Um every single core has
direct its own direct onchip memory. So
its own SRAMM. So every single core on
this wafer has a memory right next to
it. And what that means is that all of
the values that every single core needs
for computations like weights, KB cache,
etc. is directly accessible and much
faster to accessible and it's right
there.
And so as you the other and so that's a
little bit that's one example of what
Cerebrus has done on the hardware side.
Um, but going back to software, I also
want to talk about really quickly one
thing that Cerebrus implements on the
software side to accelerate inference.
And so one way that you can accelerate
inference is through a technique called
spec um standard decode or speculative
decoding. So in standard decoding you
have one model generate every single
token one at a time. And this is
sequential, right? You have to wait for
the previous token to be generated to
generate the next token.
So in speculative decoding, you combine
two models. And what you're doing is you
use a smaller model that's like a draft
model that can generate all of the
tokens very quickly. And then you use
your larger model to go back and verify
that the output of the smaller model is
correct. And by combining these two
models, you're able to get the speed of
the smaller model and the accuracy of
the larger model. And if you think about
it, your speed is capped by this uh your
like this the speed um is capped by the
speed of the larger model. So you will
up to the large like the speed will be
up to the larger model um but it will
never go beyond it. So it will only be
ever be faster.
So as a kind of a short recap, hardware,
memory, bandwidth, we talked through
that software, specular decoding, but
that was a little side moment and I want
to go
and now back to the workshop. Now that
you have all the context that you need.
>> Awesome job.
>> Yeah, thanks Sarah. Um, for those who
folks who join in late, you guys can
scan the QR code to get the starter
code. We had it in the early slide, but
um since we'll be teaching you guys how
to build these sales agents, you can
follow along with our code. Um yeah, so
I think in the future, most customer
interactions will probably be AI
powered, but you know, instead of just
typing back and forth with the chatbot,
what the best way to kind of really have
these customer interactions is really
through real conversations, which is why
voice agents are so powerful.
So before we dive deep into it, what
exactly is a voice agent?
>> Absolutely. Um so voice agents are
stateful intelligent systems that can
simultaneously run inference while
constantly listening to you when you're
speaking and they can actually engage in
real and very natural conversations. Um
I would like to highlight four key uh
capabilities. First, they understand and
respond to spoken language. um they
don't just spit out answers based on
string matching or keywords but rather
they can actually understand the meaning
behind what people are saying. Um this
also means that they can handle a lot of
complex tasks. So someone might ask like
I'm looking for a product recommendation
and the agent can subsequently kind of
look into the users's purchase history,
the shops's current stock levels and
recommend something that they actually
like. And you actually might see this
referred in some places called multi-
aent or workflows. Um speech is
obviously the fastest way to communicate
your intent in any system. We're
speaking now I guess but you can just
say what you want. There's like no
typing, no clicking through menus and no
learning learning curves. And lastly um
none of this would be possible unless
the agent can keep track of the state of
the conversation. uh which means the
communications obviously is very highly
contextual and your agents needs to have
like state so they can actually hold a
coherent conversation across time.
So as you can imagine this makes um
voice agents perfect. You see a lot of
startups happening right now especially
in customer service, sales, tech support
etc. And so today we're going to be
focusing on the sales agent use case.
So, first let's talk about what's
actually happening inside a voice agent
when you're having a conversation and
break it down.
>> Yeah. So, you guys can see on this
diagram on the right, once speech is
detected, the voice data is forwarded to
ST or that's called speech to text. This
listens and converts to your your words
to text in real time. And the last step
in this process is end of utterance um
or end of turn detection. um being
interrupted by AI every time you pause.
It's like very annoying. So, while VAD
can help the system know when you are
and you aren't speaking, it's also very
important to analyze like what you're
saying, the context of your speech, and
to predict like whether you've done
sharing your thoughts. So, we have
another small smaller model here that
runs quickly on the CPU, which will
instruct the system to wait if it
predicts you're still speaking. So, once
your turn is done, the final text
transcription is forwarded to the next
layer.
And then after that phase, we have the
thinking phase. So your entire question
is now passed onto the large language
model. Um, and this is basically, you
know, the brain like understands what
you're asking. So it might need to look
things up, which we'll walk through
later. Um, like checking in this case,
if we're doing a sales call, we'll want
to pull additional context like
documents, your other like more
information about your company
basically.
>> Yeah. And then the third and the final
step is the speaking phase. So as LM
streams response back to the agent, the
agent will immediately starts forwarding
these LLM tokens to the TTS engine or
text to speech. Um this generated um
audio from TTS streams back to your
client's application in real time and
that's why the agent can actually start
responding when it's still thinking.
So the final result is that all of these
components tied together is what's
making, you know, an AI agent that feels
very responsive, that feels very
cohesive and immediate, even though
there's a lot of complex processing
happening behind the scenes. So there's
a lot of moving pieces. In this case,
we're going to be using LiveKit's agent
SDK to handle all this orchestration for
us. Um, it's going to manage the audio
streams, keep track of the context, and
coordinate all these different AI
services that we've just talked about.
So, now that we have a little bit of
context, um you can access the starter
code here. We shared it already. And if
you want to run the first section right
here, it'll allow you to install all of
the necessary packages. So, if you click
on it, um you'll be able to see some of
the output of the packages being
downloaded. And so, this is going to use
live kit agents with support for
Cartisia, Cilero for voice activity
detection, and openAI compatibility.
And so we've very briefly talked about
Cerebras. It is 50 times faster than
GPUs. And
um I'll skip here. And so as a final
note, so for this um for this workshop,
we're actually going to be using Llama
3.3. And if you see in the chart on the
bottom right, this is a chart from
artificial analysis. Artificial
analysis, if you're unfamiliar, is an
independent benchmark that benchmarks a
lot of different models, API providers,
etc. um on intelligence, speed, latency,
everything. And so you can see a
comparison here of Cerebrus on the very
left in terms of tokens per second and
any of your other providers like Nvidia.
Awesome. Um going back to our code, um
hopefully everyone has had a second to
kind of install the packages. Um, and
now let's also in we can also install
the live CLI. This is optional for our
work workshop today, but if you want to
use live kit beyond this, um, here are
the commands depending on your system.
Um, in general, we're obviously using
Python notebook today. So, no one has to
battle around your environment when
we're getting started. But again, if you
want to continuously build and deploy uh
the voice agent, the CLI probably is the
easy way easiest way to do it. So just
uh type in LK app create and you can
instantly clone a pre-built agent like
this one.
Cool. And um let's talk a little bit
about what exactly LifeKit is and why we
need it for a voice agent. So the
existing internet isn't exactly designed
to build voice agent a uh application.
So HTTP stands for hypertext transfer
protocol. So it was designed for
transferring text over a network and
obviously for what we're building we
need to transfer voice data instead of
just text over a network with low
latency. Um and kit is a real-time
infrastructure platform for doing just
that. So instead of using HTTP actually
uses a different protocol called web RTC
to transport voice data between your
client application AI model with less
than 100 millisecond of latency anywhere
in the world which is awesome. It's very
resilient, handles a lot of concurrent
sessions and it's fully open source. So
you can kind of dig into the code and
you can see how it works or even host
infrastructure yourself as well.
Um
yeah, so you can use live kit to build
any of type of like voice agents, the
ones that can join your meetings, the
ones you're answering phone calls and
sell centers and call centers and in our
case today an agent that can speak to
prospective customers on your website on
your behalf. And here you can see
connecting it to the original diagram
that we showed. So you see like the LLM,
TTS, ST and all the AI components that
we talked about earlier. And now you can
see, you know, how these actual tools
like Live Kit, Tart, Cartisia, your
inference provider, all of these things
are actually playing together to help
you create a voice agent. And so the
final component as I mentioned is the
actual speech processing um which so in
addition to cerebrus and lifkit and as I
mentioned we'll be using cartisia to
turn the voice into text and then at the
end text back to voice.
So now that our API keys are set up step
two is all about teaching our AI sales
agent about our business. So when you
train a new employee you have to give it
information and context on your
business. And so that's what we're going
to be doing now.
>> Yeah. Um, I think the challenge a lot of
the times with LLMs is that they know a
lot about everything, but they might not
know many specific things or domain
things about your company. Um, and
they're only really as good as their
training set. So, if we want to respond
with any information that isn't common
public knowledge, we should really try
and load it into the LLM's context to
minimize hallucination or any sort of
canned responses such as, "I can't help
with that."
So, in this case, we're just going to be
feeding the LLM a document with
additional information. So, for example,
we can load our pricing details if
someone asks about pricing. But we can
also load information like product
descriptions, pricing info, key um key
benefits. And another big thing that we
can do is write pre-written responses to
common objections. So, for example, if
it's common that someone says it's too
expensive, you can write a pre-written
message so that our agent will always
stay on message and it has the correct
context. So, if you look at the
notebook, you can see what that context
looks like in practice, right? you don't
have to just give it access to a full
document. Um you can see that we've in
um organized all the information that
our sales agent needs into a very simple
structured format for the AI to
understand and reference.
So you can see everything that you um a
good salesperson would need like the
descriptions and then as we mentioned it
has these pre-written messages as well
so that you can control the out um the
behavior of your voice agent more
closely.
Um, now we're off to the more exciting
part, even more exciting part, step
three, where we actually create our
sales agent. So, this is where
everything that we've just talked about,
the components, and we're going to wire
them all together into a working system.
Um, and before you run anything, let's
actually walk through what is happening
in the sales agent class. So, in the
code, you can see we start by loading
our contacts by using the load context
function we defined earlier. And this
gives us our agent access to all the
product information, pricing, and
objection handlers that we set up.
Oh, sorry.
So, and finally, I want to look at how
we're implementing everything in code in
terms of creating the actual sales
agent. So the there's way more of the
code in the notebook, but as a high
level um you want to start there's kind
of four components. So you want to start
by you know telling your sales agent
your voice agent communicating um your
sales agent commun communicating by
voice um and give it proper rules like
you know don't use bullet points because
everything is spoken aloud. So you want
to do um a bit of prompting and then
most importantly only use information
from the context that you provided. So
you want to make be very careful
especially with voice agents that you
are not allowing um that you're reducing
the risk of hallucinations as much as
possible. And then the super call is
what's initializing our agent and passes
all of our configurations to the parent
agent. And this is setting up our agent
with the LMC TTS VA and all the
instructions working together. And then
the last thing that we're going to do is
we're also going to define an onenter
method which is what's going to start
the actual conversation. So, as soon as
someone joins the conversation with the
agent, instead of sitting in silence, it
immediately um or this is triggered as
soon as someone joins the conversation.
So, instead of ever sitting in silence,
you're going to immediately generate
that grading um and the good salesperson
will help.
Yeah. And then we're off to our step
four. We're actually launching a
sequence and running the agent. Um,
think of this entire kind of uh entry
point function as a start button to our
agent. And when someone wants to have a
conversation, obviously it kicks off
every in the gear and gets the agent
ready to talk. So this entry point
function is doing three main things. So
it's connecting the agent to a virtual
room where the conversation will happen.
So it's like dialing into a conference
call. Um, then it's going to create an
instance of our sales agent with the
setup that we just configured. And so
finally, it's going to start a session
that manages the back and forth
conversations. And so that is it for the
basis or like I guess the main framework
for how you would set up a sales agent.
But to make this project a little more
robust, we're actually going to talk
about one a few ways that you can expand
your sales agent. So
here's one example.
Yeah. So one thing you can do um to
expand our single agent into a multi-
aent system is um to just you know if
someone calls asking really deep
technical questions about API
integrations you really want them
talking to your best technical person
and not just your spicing pricing
specialist. Um again all limbs have
limited context windows which means that
similar to people they have limits on
the amount of things that they can
actually specialize. Um and here are the
three other agents in addition to that
single agent that um the the starter co
has just helped you guys run. Um three
of the different agents that we propose
in this case are um greeting agents um
our main sales agent who qual qualifies
leads. We have a technical specialist
agent as you can see on the left um who
are obviously specialized in sol solving
technical issues is the intent and then
finally we have the pricing specialist
agent on the right which handles budget
ROI and also deal negotiations. So the
main thing that you want to think about
here is you know on a real sales team
you want or any like multi- aent system
you want all of your agents to be able
to do very different things. And so one
of the key things in this um
implementation is that we have a um is
that we have a handoff. So our greeting
agent is what figuring out what the
customer actually needs and then being
able to route to the um to the relevant
sub agent.
And the code for all of these different
agents is fully fleshed out in the
notebook as well. And then the last
thing of course is you can is adding
tool calling. So for example when
someone a customer asks about technical
details you know we can properly route
and then this is also implemented as
well in the code notebook
and that is it. So thank you guys so
much for coming. Um all again all of the
notebook with all the instructions and
the step by step is in the notebook that
we're provided and have built. Um and
we'll be up here to answer any questions
that you guys might have. Thank you
guys.